[Musique]
le 9 août au matin vers 11 heures la
troisième adjointe m'appelle pour me
signaler qu'il y avait un colis
alimentaire déposés devant la maison
de tels cas d'une famille effectivement
il y avait des produits alimentaires
première nécessité en plein soleil ce
qui était tout à fait normal donc à ce
moment là j'ai voulu frapper à la porte
pour leur demander d'ouvrir pas de
réponse je vais vers le volet qui était
un peu entrebâillée je frappe sur le
volet en disant gens bien les ollier
maire ce que vous pourriez m'ouvrir je
voulais vous voir je reviens devant la
porte parce que pour m'ouvrir et serait
passé par la porte et à ce moment là la
porte ouverte très précipitamment et
sous le garçon l'office de cette
locataire avait un couteau à lame un
couteau avec une lame très long comme ça
on se profitant sûrement disant je vais
vous tuer je vais me tuer pour un
dixième de seconde
j'ai vu tout apparaître ma vie si vous
avez que mon épouse mes enfants et
petits-enfants etc et vous voyez me de
prêts là mais plutôt poser vraiment vous
essayer de survivre à ce moment là c'est
pour ça que j'ai excuses et je suis
parti alors aujourd'hui en faisant un
peu le le bilan de tout ça si vous
voulez
je garde ça ce traumatisme quand même
d'agression ça c'est sûr je pense celui
de temps en temps par maintenant le plus
est fausse et je comprends pas le geste
[Musique]
e
à 68 ans jean-pierre muselier fini son
troisième mandat de maire de symbion
petite commune de 500 habitants située
dans le puy de dôme
cet été pour la première fois
l'actualité nationale à troubler la
quiétude de ce village paisible toujours
dangereux noir je te verrai tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
l'agression de l'élu a eu un fort
retentissement dans la presse locale et
nationale
jean-pierre muselier a conservé les
articles pour les fournir à son avocat
jdd
vendredi encore le maire de saint aignan
puy-de-dôme été agressé au couteau at c
à dessus a légèrement baissé
le jdd fauvet niamey régressé par le
fils d'une amie tente qu'un petit
article
le décès du maire de sin a soulevé
l'indignation il réfute le maire de
saint léon lui aussi été victime d'une
agression n'accepte pas si vous voulez
la violence sur qui que ce soit en
particulier encore sur quelqu'un qui
détient de l'autorité les maires sont au
pgi officiers judiciaires dont il
détient l'autorité sur notre commune et
lorsqu'on se déplace on le fait dans le
cas de notre mission de mer ou de
présidente c'est pareil et donc il était
hors de question pour moi de ne pas
déposer plainte à l'encontre de
quelqu'un qui qui est dangereux
faire respecter la loi une démission du
mandat de maire sur décision de la
préfecture
il doit par exemple faire appliquer les
règles d'urbanisme autour de l'église
romane du village classé monument
historique
mais quand un habitant décide d'y
déroger
le maire n'a pas les moyens de s'y
opposer comment voulez vous qu'on fasse
il ya aucune sanction est rien venu
mettre des astreintes jeux en un coup de
fusil encore c'est impossible dans nos
communes
nous sommes malheureusement dépourvu
dans les grandes communes il ya pas de
problème des services juridiques de la
police municipale il ya les saouler tout
à tout âge je veux dire une synergie
celui que nous n'avons pas nous nous
sommes en contact en permanence avec les
administrés et donc le choc sur les mers
administrés quand l'administré n'est pas
d'accord et n'est pas content nous avons
aucune possibilité de faire plier et
c'est pas nous qui allons décider si les
services de l'état et on nous demande de
faire appliquer quelque chose sans nous
donner les moyens
donc ces deux là où il ya le problème un
sentiment d'impuissance qui n'est pas
nouveau mais qui a pris une ampleur
particulière au coeur de l'été 2010 9
avec le drame de signes
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h à la une de
l'actualité ce soir le choc et les
questions dans le var après la mort du
maire de signes il a été percuté par un
fourgon en voulant empêcher independent
les gars de gravats les réactions sont
nombreuses
emmanuel macron salue ce soir le
dévouement de l'élu un choc pour les
habitants de cette commune du var qui
dirigeait depuis 36 ans mais aussi pour
les 35000 maires de france et pour toute
la classe politique
je pense comme tous les maires de france
puisque je les ai été maire et à une
forme d'identification très humaine et
c'est bien de revenir ce qui s'est passé
au mois d'août parce que évidemment
c'est une blessure qui ne se refermera
points dès le lendemain du drame le
sénat lance une grande consultation
auprès des maires pour connaître
l'ampleur du phénomène et le
gouvernement qui avait justement
programmé un projet de loi sur les mers
à l'automne est obligé de s'adapter des
dispositions vont venir compléter le
texte
là où nous avons largement compléter le
texte c'est en cas de problème c'est pas
forcément en amont c'est quand
l'irréparable se produit une agression
qu'elle soit verbale ou physique c'est
de se dire au fond de quoi a besoin un
élu pour être accompagnés
pour finaliser ce projet de loi et
écouter les maires sébastien lecornu
invite au ministère les élus agressé
pendant l'été jean-pierre muselier le
maire de 5 millions fait évidemment
partie de la délégation avec beaucoup
d'attentes
j'arrive pour écouter l'ensemble des
mesures qu'ils vont proposer pour la
prochaine législature et à l'issue de
quoi nous allons leur poser des
questions et leur dire également notre
mal être c'est surtout ça je vais
rencontrer donc onze autres élus qui ont
lu les mêmes déboires que moi maintenant
demain matin la presse peuvent faire
état d'un maire qui s'est fait tuer
s'est fait renversé a pris un coup de
poing et c'est alors on n'est plus à
l'abri si vous voulez de tout ça on
n'est plus du tout à l'abri
tu finis
[Musique]
bonjour mes cheveux
les parlementaires chargés du dossier
sont également conviés pendant près de
trois heures le ministre est surtout
chargé de rassurer des mères parfois
traumatisé déjeuner c'était calme aussi
moyen de dire à ces mères qui ne sont
pas seuls et qu'il fallait pas non plus
à inverser les rôles c'étaient eux les
victimes s'étaient pas à eux de se
cacher ce n'était pas à eux d'être de
côté et que donc il fallait pas laisser
s'installer cette banalisation de ces
faits là pour les élus la chose est
encore plus singulière parce que c'est
pas vraiment un métier comme les autres
c'est pas vraiment un métier tout court
c'est pas non plus une fonction
associative
vous n'êtes pas gens de votre commune
donc cette singularité de l'engagement
effectif qui est un modèle bien français
là ils méritaient aussi cet
accompagnement bien français en charge
du texte au sénat
françoise gatel promet d'en tirer des
enseignements c'était pour nous un
rapporteur du texte à un moment
important pour conforter ce que nous
ressentons et de la nécessité et de la
nécessité d'agir mais je crois qu'il
faut en faire alors on prend souvent le
mot de cause nationale mais je pense que
c'est un danger pour nous tous que
vraiment on replace les maires au coeur
de l'action publique en ce qui concerne
digne de ce qu'ils en arrivent juste
parce qu'ils sont mères et qu'ils ont
osé s'engager comme s'indigner comme
agissent
le sentiment que j'ai tout de suite
c'est que nous avons été entendus
ça c'est vraiment c'est sûr on a été
entendu le ministre nous a beaucoup
remercié dans le cadre de nos fonctions
et il va y avoir je pense des
modifications encore sur ce texte de
lois des amendements ça m'engage c'est
vous voulez préparer un nouveau mandat
un quatrième mandat de maire avec un
optimisme à 100%
début octobre les sénateurs font le
bilan de la consultation lancée auprès
des maires le président de la commission
des lois philippe bas on partage les
conclusions avec les deux rapporteurs du
projet de loi sur les mers françoise
gatel et mathieu darnaud alors là si on
défend pas nous mais je crois que
vraiment c'est bien sûr c'est que notre
démocratie est tendre en péril je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez
moi je partage sur l'importance du taux
de réponse sachant qu'en plus le temps
c'était pendant l'été sur un temps
tricot et ce qui m'a aussi frappé ce
sont les incivilités ou les agressions
dont peuvent être victimes
aussi les familles des études je pense
qu'il était important qu'on puisse
répondre de façon très rapide de façon
quasiment éclair avant l'élection aux
municipales parce que ce sera à mon avis
une des clés et permettra de réinviter
certains de nos concitoyens ou d'inviter
ceux des sortants à être candidat à la
prochaine fois
[Musique]
e
grâce à cette consultation pour la
première fois un état des lieux des
violences sur les mers est effectué avec
plus de 3800 retour d'élus après un été
marqué par des faits divers les
concernant le questionnaire a été pour
les mères un véritable exutoire où ils
ont pu livrer sans filtre la réalité de
ces violences j'ai reçu une ou deux
boutons et j'étais mort au journal de 20
heures j'ai été agressé à une fourche à
dedans pointée sur levante
j'ai reçu deux coups de poing dans la
figure j'ai tant de meurtre avec une
voiture comme une arme pour tuer deux
interventions chirurgicales six mois en
un mois plus de 3800 élus ont donc
répondu au questionnaire et 92% d'entre
eux rapportent avoir subi incivilités
injures menaces ou agression 14 %
évoquent même une attaque physique soit
540 trois agressions recensées
un chiffre bien supérieur à ce qui était
connu des services de police et pour
cause puisque seulement 37 % des mères
disent avoir saisi la justice et
seulement 21 % des plaintes ont abouti à
une condamnation pénale
par conséquent nous avons adopté ce
matin 12 12 propositions d'action si ce
signal fort et entendent réussite
devient tangible par des mesures
concrètes qui sont prises immédiatement
oui cela a un effet bénéfique sur les
vocations pour les prochaines élections
municipales
12 préconisations dont une bonne partie
sera reprise par le gouvernement pour
une meilleure prise en compte des
violences sur les mers la première des
choses que nous avons renforcé même s'il
avait déjà des choses en projet les
doigts c'est de garantir à l'est un
niveau minimal un panier minimale de
services et d'accompagnement juridique
avec un système d'assurance qui permet à
chaque maire de france où chaque adjoint
au maire d'avoir l'assistance d'un
avocat quelles que soient ses revenus ou
les assurances personnelles qu'il peut
avoir par ailleurs considérant qu'un
maire il est agent de l'état dans sa
commune et donc il est bien normal que
l'état de la compagne est donc l'étape
paye cette assurance juridique pour
toutes les communes de moins de 3500
habitants n'y a pas de raison qu'on
fasse moins pour un maire ou un adjoint
au maire que pour un policier un
gendarme ou un pompier voilà bon bah ça
ce sont des mesures très concrètes
pendant deux semaines en octobre les
sénateurs ont donc débattu de ce projet
de loi baptisé engagement et proximité
souvent main dans la main parlementaires
et gouvernement ont veillé à offrir aux
élus des communes les moyens d'exercer
leurs missions
je vous propose c'est qu'on fasse une
belle oeuvre collective tous ensemble
entre le sénat quelle que soit vos
sensibilités politiques et le
gouvernement pour rendre la vie des 600
millions le coût de ce pays bien
meilleur au quotidien au service de
notre république
[Musique]
si ce texte est aussi urgent c'est que
la crise des vocations et la 50 % des
mères déclarent ne pas vouloir se
représenter en 2020
emile et lui ont même abandonné leur
poste en cours de mandat si la violence
est un des aspects la technicité
toujours plus importante du mandat de
maire est aussi un frein
l'enjeu de la formation est donc
primordial
ce jour-là à toulouse c'est l'organisme
élu local point fr qui promeut la place
des femmes en politique qui dispensent
une formation sur les finances des
communes
je suis très heureux de vous accueillir
à cette formation
concernant les finances de la
collectivité 1
maîtrisé mais le discours le vocabulaire
du budget nous allons voir aujourd'hui
le contexte général des finances des
collectivités tout déjà élu dans des
conseils municipaux ou au département
les participantes viennent se former en
fin de mandature faute d'avoir eu avant
les crédits suffisants n'a pas ces
pratiques tout le monde à se former est
donc là il y avait les propositions
finances c'était l'occasion je brigue un
mandat de maire de la commune à nouveau
et je viens ici pour me remettre à jour
des connaissances d'il ya 25 ans on va
dire je conduis aujourd'hui une équipe
pour les prochaines municipales sur le
petit village qui complique 500
habitants qui est dans le département
des pyrénées-orientales tout proche de
perpignan
si ça n'est pas seule capitale de la
nation
est-ce qu'on peut tout mettre en
investissement ou alors il faut
rembourser en priorité donc
effectivement le capital de la dette
1 ce qui est logique enfin pas
rembourser l'emprunt mais rentrer en
bourse et le capital des grands
solitaires de la dette
et après tout le reste effectivement
c'est un investissement pourquoi bien
sûr là on a parlé de budget c'est le
nerf de la guerre on le sait et en
discutant avec mes collègues on échange
des expériences et des idées est déjà là
j'ai de nouvelles propositions à faire à
ma future liste sur comment gérer la
commune toutes ces questions là
effectivement ces questions qu'elle
n'est absolument pas préparée quand on
est élu
on a pour soi que sa volonté son envie
de bien faire on se heurte parfois
effectivement des difficultés une
méconnaissance du droit et je crois
qu'effectivement ça devrait être quelque
part comme une obligation ou une
proposition faite à tous les élus de
pouvoir aller se former de manière à ne
pas se confronter à des difficultés qui
pourraient être facilement évité les
élus quand il commence donc y en a qui
on leur première mandature donc et un
socle un petit peu de formations savoir
ce qui se passe que fait encore ces
municipales un peu de pédagogie d'une
journée deux journées en plusieurs fois
mais qui connaissent un petit peu comme
je vous disais précédemment les rouages
c'est très important de commencer parce
qu'ils se sentiront plus à l'aise et
et pourront surtout assumer le lourd
mandat de plus de facilité il faut tout
de suite mettre les lui et notamment le
prime aux élus à l'aise je deviens maire
ou adjoint au maire je te parle de
complexes informé aujourd'hui un
complexe la formation elle a des vertus
humaines moi j'y crois beaucoup
certes des gros morceaux du projet de
loi mine de rien ça n'a l'air de rien
mais c'est ce qui fait aussi qu'on
donnera le goût à l'engagement jeu même
le dire autrement c'est ce qui fait que
peut-être on gomorra le dégoût peut-être
parfois lorsqu'on s'engage en disant
mais bon sang si tu que c'est compliqué
je n'étais pas préparé à ça va donc tout
simplement il faut savoir y répondre et
dont il faut préparer les bonnes
volontés qui s'engage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'engagement arnaud lafon connaît bien
alors on y va avec vous un détient
à 44 ans ce père célibataire hf déjà son
troisième mandat de maire de castanet
tolosan ville située dans
l'agglomération toulousaine
t'as quoi aujourd'hui
[Musique]
dans la première mission de la mer c'est
d'être aussi perd donc d'accompagner son
enfant l'école tout simplement un
importante seul collège avec lui les
journées se déroulent tout pas de chat
bien vous réprimer photo pl j'ai vu ça
bon vous avez vu là enfin si vous voulez
passerait comme ça fera l'eau avant
après merci bien
et il lui faut jongler entre ses
différentes casquettes familiale
municipale et de contrôleur de gestion
en entreprise
des journées bien remplies avec un
agenda tenue au cordeau alors
aujourd'hui ben une audition mariage
franco étrangers de
10 à 11 un rendez vous téléphonique en
salle des marchés pour taupe et dans le
cadre du passage en taux fixe d'un
emprunt à taux variable et toute la
journée et au diapason
les horaires c'est très variable ça peut
commencer par une réunion à 8 heures à
toulouse et se terminer par un conseil
de communauté agglomération à minuit ça
fait des belles journées ça hop abbas
heloisa retiens ça ses mains n'a pas eu
d'indemnité
ça vous intéresse hop voilà alors comme
j'aime bien la publier toute façon sur
sur facebook comme je publie mon avis de
revenus comme je publie mon avis de
revenus d'imposition voilà une unité de
maire d'une commune de 13 mille
habitants moi j'ai décidé de fixer mon
indemnité net au montant le plus bas
perçue par un employé à temps plein dans
la collectivité
serge est pas un employé sur ma
collectivité qui touchent moins que moi
en équivalent temps plein ça donne une
certaine liberté d'action quand on a
envie de discuter avec eux mais dans
l'inconscient collectif mais les élus
sont des personnes qui sont privilégiés
qui ont un train de vie que n'ont pas
les autres habitants et
sont des postes qui sont enviées quand
on ne les connaît pas quand on les
connaît on revient un petit peu on
révise le logiciel une démarche carnot
la faune peut se permettre grâce à ses
revenus de contrôleur de gestion en
entreprise
mais il est bien conscient que tout le
monde n'a pas cette chance à un moment
donné si on veut des élus qui ressemble
un petit peu l'ensemble des habitants il
faut qu'ils puissent avoir une activité
professionnelle
aujourd'hui conseiller une activité
professionnelle avec une fonction
élective
ça reste très difficile j'ai pour ma
part pu bénéficier d'un environnement
professionnel et familial qui fait que
je travaille en coopération un
partenariat dans la sphère familiale
donc j'ai pu adapter mes horaires de
travail mais cette capacité d'adaptation
que l'on peut avoir dans le privé c'est
très rare suite à votre audition
préalable pour votre mariage donc on a
échangé sur tout un tas de
questionnaires élu maire à seulement 25
ans arnaud lafon va maintenant tourner
la page de la politique municipale
autant parce qu'il considère qu'il faut
cesser le cumul des mandats dans le
temps que par choix de vie ça fait donc
trois mandats que je suis en poste 19
ans de ma vie je pense qu'il est un
moment donné qu'une nouvelle génération
prenne le relais au niveau de l'action
municipale
les vingt dernières les est consacrée à
m'occuper des autres essayer de gérer
une collectivité un bien public les 20
prochaines années j'ai peut-être est
consacré un petit peu plus à ma vie
professionnelle à mon environnement
familial à mon enfant que j'ai pas vu
forcément grandir les dix premières
années de sa vie
ou du moins autant que j'aurais souhaité
donc c'est peut-être consacré un petit
peu plus de temps cela entrée
avec l'émergence d'une nouvelle
génération d'élus qui ne consacreront
pas forcément toute leur vie à la
politique
la question de la conciliation vie
professionnelle et vie des lieux va de
plus en plus se pose
nous sommes tous d'accord sur le constat
précisément avec le sénat avec les
associations d'élus personnes
globalement de fait de propositions
renversante sur le sujet parce que si on
va trop loin
on rend les élus inemployables ou alors
même on les met en difficulté en porte à
faux avec leurs concitoyens donc la
question de la représentation de l'ue
salarié reste un objet qui est devant
nous encore
[Musique]
des parcours de mer qui évolue mais
aussi des communes qui change
nes ou disparaissent finie l'époque des
36000 communes françaises depuis 2010 9
le pays en compte mais moins de 35 mille
suite à des fusions de communes
c'est le cas en ile et vilaine entre
rennes et saint-malo ou trois communes
se sont en quelque sorte marié saint
pierre de plesguen lent et l'un est
tressé sont devenus une seule et même
ville au 1er janvier 2019
mesnil rock une commune nouvelle qui
réunit quatre mille trois cents
habitants au coeur du pays du granit
bleu des fusions de communes que je suis
particulièrement la sénatrice françoise
gatel agir christelle comment tu va très
bien j'ai vu les travaux
la plate forme donc bien la fusion a eu
lieu il ya moins d'un an et qui dit
fusion de communes ne dit pas forcément
davantage d'éloignement en fait l'équipe
notre idée majeure c'est de se dire on
se met ensemble pour renforcer notre
proximité c'est pas pour aller ailleurs
c'est vraiment pour se dire on est
capable de faire plus ensemble sur de
local fait il ya longtemps que les
équipes de foot des trois communes elle
s'était mise en chambre qu'il y avait
des regroupements d'écoles et donc un
moment les élus et pouge on va dire le
périmètre de vie des gens et parce
qu'ils sont très attachés à leur commune
et c'est justement pour ça parce qu'ils
l'apportent profondément et avec
conviction
ils veulent la projeter dans l'avenir et
que se projeter dans l'avenir c'est
parfois faire évoluer la frontière mais
gardait tu l'a très bien des gardes et
de la proximité
bon bah cristal merci encore ton accueil
merci beaucoup de vibrations aux
plaisirs travail je viendrai fêter la
première bougie par le genre avec
plaisir très bien au revoir mon retour
bon ben maintenant on va aller faire un
tour à halle en velin et puis voir les
réalisations que l'on a pu faire sur sur
l'anglin communes déléguées au clan ben
ali n'y à la mairie si la nouvelle
mairie centrale est située dans
l'ancienne commune de saint pierre de
plesguen les deux autres villages ont
conservé leur mairie ça devient quand
étienne ménard était le maire de
lanhélin depuis 2014
il est désormais simplement maire
délégué mais pour lui ce n'est pas un
souci puisque sa commune peut désormais
bénéficier de services comme un portail
internet commun ou la restauration
scolaire autrefois sous traiter et de
mauvaise qualité
on s'est donné la capacité là en moins
de neuf mois de produire aussi pour les
enfants de l'école de long et lent donc
c'est tous les midis et bien s'il 60
repas de plus qui sont faits à
saint-pierre et qui sont servis ici à
lons et là c'était un des objectifs
d'ailleurs vent le vent donc la création
de la commune nouvel an
évoquer ce sapin c'est un souci pour
pour moi personnellement la qualité de
la nourriture pour les enfants c'est
quand même très important
les services qui est né à saint pierre
au contraire c'est qu'ils soient plus
utilisés mieux utiliser la limite il
était sous utilisé vous optimisez les
optimiser en mettant leurs moyens en
commun ils ont aussi rompu l'isolément
que peuvent ressentir les petits maires
euros c'est quand même maintenant plus
facile de prendre des décisions en
parlant comme un cas décision un peu
compliqué à prendre on en parle demain
christelle ont partagé c'est c'est un
soulagement
j'ai mis un mouchoir sur mon ego pour ça
parce que quand on est maire on
représente un petit peu là comment dire
toi et tes de la commune enfin jaurès
on représente toujours autorités de la
commune mais bon on se dit que l'on va
perdre un petit peu de notoriété de ne
pouvoir et ça c'est pas c'est pas du
tout mon objectif pendant la gestion de
communes
moi ma fierté dans la commune c'est de
faire en sorte qu'elle se porte bien
qu'ils aient des investissements qu'ils
se fassent que l'école va bien etc
mais je sais pas c'est pas pour me
notoriété et ça ça ne me gêne pas du
tout bien au contraire
madame la maire et le maire délégué sont
désormais pleins de projets comme
l'accueil d'une maison de retraite sur
la commune de lanhélin qui n'aurait pu
se faire sans la création de la commune
ii men il rentre au palais du luxembourg
pendant quinze jours sénateurs et
gouvernement ont donc débattu de toutes
ces adaptations pour accompagner et
faciliter la vie des mères et à l'heure
du vote solennel
c'est une unanimité très rare qui se
dégage de l'hémicycle
il y aura des réponses pour faciliter au
quotidien l'exercice du rôle des élus et
plus particulièrement de celui de maire
nous avons voulu dire que pour nous il
n'y a qu'une collectivité qui vaille
dans le bloc communal
c'est la commune parce qu'elle
représente tout pour nos concitoyens
notre groupe pragmatique mais vigilant
exigent votre à ce projet doit le nombre
de suffrages exprimés de 340 pour
l'adoption 338 2 compte je crois qu'il
ya une unanimité du sénat pour
effectivement redonner aux élus locaux
de la liberté et leur affirmer la
confiance à la fois du gouvernement mais
surtout des sénateurs pour que les élus
retrouvent de la capacité à agir de la
liberté et surtout qu'on l'aura exprime
notre confiance dans leur sens des
responsabilités
redonner la confiance et tenter
d'endiguer le blues des mères qui
s'était installée avec en ligne de mire
les prochaines élections municipales de
mars 2020
[Musique]
je